[Music]
the United States is remarkably secure
but you wouldn't sort of get that sense
if you listened to our president or the
members of Congress who constantly are
finding threats out there to America's
security and I I don't want to be in the
position to deny that there are
challenges out there but you know I'd
really strongly urge us to put these
challenges in their proper context so
let's talk about one of the challenges
de jour the North Korean regime under
the odious dictator Kim jong-un's
frenetic and a sustained pursuit of a
nuclear capability there's no doubt that
the North Korean regime is a terrible
regime inflicting suffering mostly on
its own people and I you know freely
concede that the world would be better
off if they didn't have a nuclear
capability and the question then is how
much of a threat does this pose to the
United States and my answer contrary to
the hyperventilating that you see and a
lot of the discussion of this topic is
that it really doesn't change things
very much to begin with the United
States is one of the largest nuclear
powers in the world currently our
arsenal consists of about 4000 nuclear
warheads that are deliverable in a wide
variety of very reliable packages
contrast that with North Korea which may
have you know 20 to 30 atomic devices
that may or may not be deliverable on
anything other than short-range
ballistic missiles now most people would
concede that the balance is very much in
our favor but say
this is a crazy regime I mean couldn't
this be a case in which a madman has his
finger on the nuclear trigger and I
don't want to defend Kim jong-un's
rationality or his sartorial choices but
I would say that he's learned the lesson
that many other dictators have learned
from Saddam Hussein and from Muammar
Qaddafi which is if you don't want to be
invaded by the United States build
whatever rudimentary nuclear arsenal you
can now you can't eat nuclear weapons
and a residual nuclear arsenal I think
is no guarantee that the North Korean
regime won't collapse of its own
internal rottenness
in fact I anticipate that that's what
will happen
and that'll present its own set of
challenges
but there are a very different set of
challenges than the ones that we've been
talking about in the general political
discourse about the North Korea and
nuclear threat in our country so the
question then is what the United States
should do about North Korea the
challenge that the United States faces
is when the regime goes south is it
invariably will won't be tomorrow could
be five years could be ten years it's
going to pose to the United States a
challenge and the challenge involves two
elements first of all the United States
and the South Koreans will be tempted if
a civil war starts in the north or even
if there's just large-scale social
unrest to intervene the South to reunify
their country the United States to try
to clean up the nuclear capability but
the problem is that there's another
great power with
in North Korea and that's China and the
Chinese are not particularly fond of the
Kim regime but they're sort of stuck in
a dysfunctional marriage with them they
don't want a reunited Korea under Seoul
with nuclear weapons on their border and
so the real problem that we face is how
we manage the inevitable endgame of a
collapsing North Korea with China and
here the solution is a explicit set of
discussions and agreements with the
Chinese about what will happen in this
context and I think we'd be well advised
to start now dialoguing with the Chinese
about the future and I think a unified
Korea but also one without nuclear
weapons and non-aligned without a major
US military presence could be the deal
that would work for everybody
[Music]